I think that because the geneticists
that are still around can still exert
influence on the younger geneticists
that are coming up I think that the
ethical responsibility to grow and
preserve and sustained landrace systems
will survive and those cuisines that are
based on land race cuisines that are
placed based will return and thrive that
means that if you're growing some
obscure apple that it actually fits into
something larger than the straight
concept of buckles or pie or anything or
syrup that it actually relates as an
apple to a dish that's place-based that
is unique to that area and that the land
race ideas of these foods we're always
influenced by other areas but they will
never be homogenized they won't be
monolithic you won't have the same
interpretation of the land race plants
even if they're the same ones grown in
this county in that county you'll have
different interpretations of that and
they'll be more of these kind of foods
available they will never dominate I
don't think we do have to feed the world
some way shape or form and no one
including me has an answer with landrace
systems at this point I would love for
somebody to do that I think going back
to another question if somebody wants to
fund something that's something to fund
is it possible to develop a land ray
system that can be set in place intact
not just certain crops as we're doing
through unesco in the NGO system but the
entire system is it possible to set that
in place and survive that's the one we
should be studying and we're not so
having said that if everybody just takes
a few of these things and grows them if
i have a 3,000 acre
arm and I'm doing cattle pasture wheat
corn soy whatever if i just take as my
ethical responsibility like paying taxes
like defending my country if i take the
pre-world War two attitude of the
American farmer in the agrarian ideal
and say it's my ethical responsibility
to go five acres of some sort of land
race system not just one grain not just
one plant one being but some sort of
land race system that can be my kitchen
garden if nothing else it would serve me
but that's what I should do on top of my
whatever a thousand acres I've got if
everybody involved in that does that I
think that just the kitchen garden
movement alone that the liberty garden
movement which my mother remembers and
everybody I know remembers that wouldn't
if they're my age and older which is
very cool I think that's not enough I
think that the farmers that are out
there that have large farms need to
think about scale and need to provide
expertise and provide preservation
provide repatriation services provide
sustaining services for Landry systems
that keep biodiversity out there so that
down the pike if we need something it's
not a hundred grams in a starving gene
bank somewhere that actually not just
the scientists are the only people
responsible for keeping these things
this is what I really care about that we
actually get it out there and so the
language we look for to make this
relevant has to come forward certainly
from the scientific community so you're
not making things up as you go and then
you have to have integrity but you have
to have brought understandings very very
difficult very difficult to make that
bridge but i think that farmers should
just start that's my current message
just get something and start growing it
because that's what farmers do they grow
things and i think that they don't think
it's their responsibility because we
have the USDA we have simit we did it
was never predicated that the people at
CIMMYT or sea otter or the Asia rice
foundation or the u.s.
the AGR am system we're going to be the
only people engaged in this and then
somehow it comes back to us through this
monolithic seed system someday it was
never predicated for that to be these
were agencies all of them set up to
serve the public as well and I think the
public has drifted away from that and as
the interest for growing your own foods
comes back I think then looking 40 years
ahead you see I wouldn't be the
exception I'll be the rule you'll have
landrace rice there's rice grown right
here in the Northeast right now takeshi
Yogi and his wife Linda are doing sr I
rice they're doing rice and the purpose
of that rice is to do tributary
watershed protection from run off
because the rice sucks it up and then
you can serve the northeastern rice
market with local rice production
everybody thinks this is so crazy in a
land ray system it's nothing it's done
the world over and it always has been
this is something that I think will be
40 years down the road I don't think it
will take 40 years for that I think you
did cachet and his wife will probably
interest enough people over the next 10
years that we may be net zero on rice up
here maybe even exporting rice in the
Northeast that's near and dear to my
heart since I'm a rice person but I
think it's extraordinary that it could
be food that we know it was grown in
Vermont who ever heard of rice being
grown in Vermont oh boy it's Vermont
rice why not okay I live in Burlington
I'm going to have some Vermont rice
that's what's going to happen in the
next 40 years